I eat her too yes harvest that [ __ ]
genki raising his corpses our water
supplies dangerously low [ __ ] that about
you you it is [ __ ] up but house can we
get out of it oh [ __ ] so I'm doing too
good um look just like sold them our
[ __ ] [ __ ] I fix it this guy's to
sleep sleep in a good bed
we got plenty of water now
drink some water it's a myth and I gotta
sleep you know take it easy take it easy
oh [ __ ] it's next week so hope y'all
enjoy hope y'all enjoyed my skit
Thursday look she's not looking good she
says to shower and fix it we're at it um
yeah sure Arthur sure I don't think we
need any of this stuff I get the [ __ ]
out my face out there okay
hex this [ __ ]
mmm is that Shannon it's just fine oh
it's Christopher [ __ ] this guy really
got to go and fix that [ __ ]
all right Shannon add some field of that
and then you are going to go on
something
super impatient guy [ __ ] is that arms
dealer
[ __ ] let's do this [ __ ] we had a fuel
yes and [ __ ] well
blackrain on surface that is [ __ ] up
yes search it search it yeah yeah let's
go let's go let's go then it some
[ __ ] petrol yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
all right I should probably eat meat
while there's still lectures today just
my guess who jump this take this got
this take this
Jesus is gonna [ __ ] up Oh an
experienced survivor yes
yeah bet broadcast for traders
and then breakfast traitor shelter
[ __ ]
okay metal hinge pipe valve
okay looks like we had all gone away no
more no way David get the [ __ ] away from
my face I can t like honestly now what
is some [ __ ] that weight on it okay um
any [ __ ] here that's just like total
[ __ ] like gonna be pissed okay let's see
what else here empty put your cans get
all this [ __ ] that's just waiting till
you burned and centre-right this [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] where is he [ __ ] nut you got
to do this first and then shower and
then sleep
[ __ ] to get rid of this
hmm
oh yeah yeah yeah good good good let's
see what's here [ __ ]
that snake or that [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
he'll a [ __ ] come on comic comic comic
[ __ ]
good good thing good
hmm
put on that hazmat suit and harvest that
trap bad idea Brian Brian now get a [ __ ]
away very bright broadcast out your head
as such as okay go baby
is that workbench
[ __ ] see what [ __ ] plastic thing
well I say you take plastic
oh good yes okay who got the brains here
craft item yes baby yes well [ __ ] we are
in business Oh baby I just came I just
came I just came
ah alright and this day looks like her
are gonna be on in this episode pretty
soon but on a high note on a high note
okay Shannon Shannon change that Shannon
eat it han yes yes you can you can now
let's say well you got here hey that's a
nice items here you had some real nice
items here um paint bucket not now well
what do you like see we get rid of
tablets cuz you know someone's sick sick
and Dives they can just can just you
know feel okay I look too okay up
shedding or [ __ ]
recycle some [ __ ]
you
whoo and
okay we are going to need another water
so now we're just gonna make this place
like dope okay you're not dope mins show
he's a plastic extra four slots that's
pretty dope
mmm let's see what can this guy make
what's up man I'm i upgraded tier 3 get
a hinge need [ __ ] plastic weird you
there
what if I deconstruct this [ __ ] make
a good bed